the changing of the guard at the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier in Arlington
National Cemetery is one of the many
roles of the Army's old guard the unit
conducts more than 6,000 ceremonies each
year including funeral escorts parades
and presidential events former old guard
platoon leader Senator Tom cotton gives
us an inside look at the Army's oldest
active duty regiment in his new book
sacred duty a soldiers tour at Arlington
National Cemetery senator cotton good
morning good to have you here we're
gonna talk about that the old guard in a
bit but first happy birthday thank you
42 42 starting to get up there it's a
crazy man at the table I will say this
you know I spent much of the last year
back at Arlington National Cemetery
researching sacred duty with the
soldiers of the old guard and a lot of
those soldiers to include those tomb
sentinels or 19 or 20 years old a little
old when I'm back at the cemetery Fort
Myer with the soldiers of the old guard
senator I want to ask you about the
trade negotiations that are going on
right now there was that just recently a
University of Arkansas study from your
home state that said retaliatory tariffs
by China could end up hurting many
farmers in your state is President Trump
hurting the Americans that he promised
to help so these tariffs are gonna end
up hurting both the Chinese and some
Americans I'll grant you that
I think the ultimately hurt the Chinese
more than they will Americans in part
because Chinese companies and their
government have been cheating the United
States for so long there will be some
sacrifice on the part of Americans I
grant you that but I also would say that
sacrifice is pretty minimal compared to
the sacrifices that our soldiers make
overseas that our fallen heroes or laid
to rest in Arlington make that are right
about here those two sacrifices that's
rice and the way when I'm home in
Arkansas hear from farmers who are
worried about opening up new markets and
getting their products to market but
they also understand that China is a
serious competitor of the United States
and wants to displace us around the
world and they look at the sacrifices
that soldiers sailors airmen and Marines
make around the world and they are
willing to bear some of those sacrifices
in the short term hopefully in the long
term ensure our long-term prosperity and
security why not tell them now in the
front
and why not tell them this sacrifice and
the higher prices you'll receive you
know you're gonna have to pay or a part
of this conflict as opposed to saying
what's not true which is that China's
gonna pay these tariffs to the Treasury
well China will ultimately be paying a
price for these because Americans may be
shifting their consumption or their
investment decisions away from Chinese
products that have oftentimes been
dumped in the United States you know we
have our Kansans who are benefitting
from these tariffs as well you know with
eastern Arkansas we have one of the
largest steel production areas now in
the country they obviously are doing
very well again I'm not gonna say that
no one is going to make a sacrifice but
in the long term the effort is to make
sure that the United States remains
preeminent as a global superpower both
in the economic and the security since
it seems to translate between 700 to
$1,000 for the average American family
which is a lot for many families is it
worth that cost if we remain the world's
largest economy and the world's dominant
superpower in the short term I say this
worth that cost and what I hear from
most are kanzan is that they are willing
to bear a short-term price not be
straight with that because you know you
have obviously Walmart matters a lot in
your stage largest retailer in the world
and they say about this hike they says
it's going to create a serious burden on
families it's just a question of you
know people don't like politicians
because sometimes they don't tell them
what's coming and have they really been
you say that and yeah I don't know many
farmers or ranchers in Arkansas who were
confused about what was going to happen
here I mean they obviously they they
have from the very beginning you know
from the minute you know 200 years ago
we started farming land in Arkansas knew
that overseas markets were vital to
their prosperity and to have new markets
sell their crops or their products but
ultimately they also know that we cannot
let China continue to cheat as they have
been for 30 years well we've talked to
farmers who seem to disagree with that
and I'm curious about your definition of
short-term what does that mean short
term
I hope sooner rather than later you know
the president said that we were close to
having an agreement within the last week
or two and that China started trying to
renegotiate the terms of the deals they
often happen time I think it's the right
thing to do is to hold China to their in
their the end of their bargain and not
give them an easy deal I think a lot a
lot of people who are criticizing the
tariff snail would be criticizing the
president
if he had given if he had struck a bad
deal with China last week let me ask you
about sacred duty it's an extraordinary
service that these soldiers provide you
were a part of that what was the hardest
part of that training and and and being
in that part of the service they're
performing funerals in the cemetery is
pressure-packed job is also very
humbling lieutenant colonel Allen Keogh
is the battalion commander for the
battalion that has primary
responsibility for the cemetery he is a
veteran of the elite 75th Ranger
Regiment he served five overseas combat
doors and he said about his time in
Arlington I've never felt pressure like
this anywhere in the army and that's
because even though we might perform
twenty to thirty funerals a day you know
over a hundred a week for that family
that is a once-in-a-lifetime moment that
is truly a no-fail zero defect mission
give people some sense of the amazing
discipline for the smallest little
detail so as I described in sacred duty
soldiers spend hundreds of hours
learning their craft which is different
from most of what the army does from
preparing their uniforms pressing them
building their medals shining their
shoes all those details though are not
just for show or for fussing us there or
to show that last in Della's indelible
image of Honor to the family and I think
most readers of sacred duty would be
able to take away an inspiring story of
excellence and commitment to one's craft
whether it's in the workplace or in
one's church or coaching a little league
team that's an inspiring ethos that
these soldiers in the old guard show for
our nation's fallen that I think any of
us can apply to our day to day life the
time the care and the respect that goes
into it is really remarkable and you
have one line that says history lives
inside Arlington gates but the old guard
never takes a break from history every
single day funerals are happening at but
every single day history is being made
as well at literally the day I turned in
the manuscript for this book is the day
President George HW Bush passed away so
for the next six days I lived that
experience with the old guard kind of in
real time and as I write about in the
conclusion of sacred duty that's one of
the rarest events they perform it's also
one of the highest stakes that's why
when I was there just like today the old
guard will train with its sister
services regularly to be prepared for a
state funeral because you never know
when something like that might happen
having
stood up close from the side of a grave
it is the most amazing thing and it's
such a testament and so glad you wrote
this book Thank You senator cough thank
you sacred duty as soldiers tour at
Arlington National Cemetery goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy books